okay so I think Memento is one of my
favorite Christopher Nolan films and
it's arguably the movie that put him on
the map the film really carved out his
signature style due to its
non-chronological storytelling it's a
movie that to this day can maybe you're
still scratching your head throughout
this video we're going to be giving a
big breakdown of what happens in it the
hidden details and also the Easter eggs
that make it one of the best movies the
directors put out huge thank you for
watching the video all the way through
and if you want something else to watch
then one of our breakdowns will be
linked on the screen right now by the
way thanks for checking out the video
I've been Paul let's see you next time
take care well it is Memento so we have
to go backwards and this is shown from
the opening shot of the film here we see
Leonard's hand holding a Polaroid
picture which is fully developed however
as he shakes it it starts to blend fade
away because it's actually moving in
Reverse this is very symbolic as it's
also how Leonard's memory works now in
the movie we discover he has a condition
and this renders him unable to create
short-term memories so to him the moment
is Chris still clear when it first
happens and then it starts to fade like
the Polaroid we see here now this is the
murder of Teddy who we see throughout
the movie is actually a policeman that's
using Leonard for his own personal gain
Memento is very much a Revenge story on
a number of levels and we see several
characters that embody this ideology
Leonard believes that his wife was
killed by a man called John G and
Teddy's weaponized this to make him his
own personal assassin Teddy has been
framing people and then leaving
breadcrumbs so that Leonard will track
down this person and in the end murder
them these tend to be high-stake drug
dealers and thus Teddy makes up with the
prophets while Selena thinks that he's
caught his wife's killer for roughly a
couple of minutes now we discover in the
film that Lenny killed a man called
Jimmy G and the money teddies actors in
the back of his car Leonard takes his
car with him and on a second watch it
becomes clear that Teddy is constantly
trying to get his hands on the keys my
car this is your car oh you're in a
playful mood
well if you win them
Republican rhetoric about taxes it's
broke I need that fixed for it
the car this nice you should lock it's
not safe for you to hang around here
anymore because
the cops looking for you now I got to
get you a new identity some new clothes
a different car would do for now love
how this Stacks up a second time with
Teddy basically trying to manipulate
Lenny into giving him the car at several
points he's not the only person who uses
landed either and in the movie we meet
Natalie who's played by Carrie Anne Moss
we discover that Jimmy G was her
boyfriend and throughout the film she
uses Lenny is her assassin to get the
person who did it it's basically revenge
for what Cipher did to switch in The
Matrix not like this
not like this
well at the end of the movie reveals
that Lenny was always gonna kill teddy
and after learning the truth he created
his own game so that he would track him
down he's finally liberating himself of
the life he's been forced into by making
Teddy a Target we close out with him
going to a tattoo store to start the
entire game again with Petty as his next
hit this is called Emma's tattoos and
it's actually named after Nolan's
real-life wife now the tattoos are an
important way for Leonard to know what
to do and who to trust whether he also
has other methods in the movie he talks
about how you'll learn to trust your own
handwriting and when Teddy pressures him
into making a note about Natalie he
writes down do you not trust her later
on this is scribbled out so you can
write about how she's also lost someone
now we can see the handwriting styles
are different here as well the first he
wrote differently because it was Teddy
telling him to do it and therefore later
on he knew not to trust what this said
Natalie 2 turns out to be a bad person
and Nolan stated that the scribble is
also used to show how ineffective
Lenny's photo system is one thing can be
put on it and then scribbled out so yeah
it just causes more uncertainty now
Beyond his wife there's very little that
we learn about Lenny and his story in
between her death and his quest for
Revenge however there was an in Canon
website created by Nolan that gave her
some extra tidbits it's said that
Leonard was put into a mental
institution and we know in the film that
semi-jancis was in one two Asami was the
man that Lenny projected himself onto in
order to try and understand the
condition that he developed Sammy could
very much be a real person and Leonard
talks about how he denied his insurance
claim because he didn't believe in his
condition however due to the
similarities in their stories it's also
possible that Sammy and Lenny are one
and the same with the latter using him
very much as a way to understand what's
wrong with him Sami ended up in a mental
Asylum as well and we do get a brief
moment where he sat in a chair pay close
attention to this though and we get a
quick flicker of Lenny hitting at him
actually being the one in the Asylum
this is a detail I've missed so many
times when watching in the past as it's
on screen for a split second but as the
person passes we can see the switch out
now Leonard is often called Lenny Lenny
it's Leonard
like I told you before yeah
forgot sorry I've been I've been calling
you Lenny a lot and Lenny is of course
similar sounding to Sammy to add to this
when he flicks through the police files
we see a psychiatric paper and we just
have to look at the short story for more
confirmation of this now the order of
this was backwards much like the film
itself though the opening credits say
that the movie is based on the short
story by Jonathan Nolan that actually
released after the film did Jonathan
went to Christopher with the idea and
Chris said it would make a great movie
which is when they start to work on that
the movie released in 2000 and the story
itself ended up dropping in 2001 titled
Memento Mori this Latin phrase
translates to remember that you have to
die the short story also has Leonard
escaping from a mental Asylum and when
you think about it someone with this
condition would need constant Medical
Care Now Teddy goes to pick Leonard up
and this is very much the other side of
the story though momento is often
thought of being a film that moves
backwards there are two parts to it we
also have the black and white sea scenes
which move forward and they involve
Leonard talking to Teddy on the phone at
the end of the movie these two timelines
join up and this is shown by the black
and white film changing into color in
the opening Leonard makes a joke about
the Gideon Bible and he ends up saying
hey nothing except the Gideon Bible
which which I of course read religiously
now in the movie we get a shot of this
being open and it's on levictus 24. this
chapter talks about an eye for an eye
which very much sums up the idea for
Revenge that's pushing Leonard forward
it also says that if a man kills a man
then he must be killed himself and
because Lenny believes Teddy killed his
wife he must suffer the same fate and
the fact that Teddy is also a John G2
explains why he ends up giving this fake
name he doesn't want Leonard potentially
turning his attention to him and thus he
lies to him from the start of the movie
or or rather the end Now lies are very
important in the film with the notes on
Teddy's Polaroids saying don't believe
his lies interestingly Teddy's phone
numbers on the Polaroid do and this
number is actually also the same one
that Marla has in Fight Club in these
scenes you can also see that Leonard had
scratches on his face and throughout the
movie these get stronger and stronger
that's because time is moving backwards
and thus really great attention to
detail by Nolan that just keeps up the
whole chronology of the movie now Lenny
meets the motel click but who you'll
probably recognize from starring in
Nolan's movie Batman Begins later on we
also see a Batman symbol up in a shop
window showing how it's all connected
Elena explains her the last thing that
he remembers is his wife he's constantly
feeling like his wife was just killed
and he can't escape this however we
learned that she actually survived this
encana and that she became distraught
with the fact that Leonard couldn't
remember her in the film we learn about
how Sammy's wife used to test him by
doing things like hiding food to see if
he'd find it when he's hungry this was
originally supposed to be in the movie
but Nolan decided to remove the scene
and just keep the focus on Leonard all
the stuff with Sammy was a rich
originally meant to be bundled together
so we got all the black and white stuff
in one go however Nolan decided that it
worked better split throughout the movie
so that the scenes could reflect the
ones moving backwards now she too asked
him to inject her with insulin which he
did several times giving her a lethal
dose letting even creates tattoos for
himself with a ballpoint pen and it's
possible that he's good at doing this
because he was so used to using needles
on his wife Lenny talks about how happy
his wife was but in the flashbacks we
see here it seems like she's either
crying or at least on the verge of tears
now I actually think that some of these
memories are from after her head was
struck and these are flashes of her
struggling to deal with the fact he
can't remember her he was the one who
killed her and thus a story's been
manufactured in order to hide him from
the guilt Nolan's stated that the movie
is very much about the lies you tell
yourself in order to give things meaning
and we definitely see this reflected in
Lenny's actions at the end or all this
thought now Leonard and his wife were
attacked and though he got the first
person at the second Asylum got away the
police didn't believe there was a second
attacker and thus he flew under the
radar by that Teddy was the one cop that
believed him they tracked down the
attacker and ended up killing him how
about from this point Teddy saw an
opportunity and his greed eventually led
to his downfall had a diner Lennon meets
with Natalie and we can see that she has
a slightly bust up lip this is something
that Leonard actually gives her and it's
a way that Natalie gains the upper hand
on him by using him to be there so that
she can weaponize his attack she used
him to get a man named Dotty was after
her and she had herself beaten up so it
seemed like Dodd did it now later on in
the movie Teddy explains how Natalie
carries out drug deals and this is done
by passing coasters from the bar that
she works at notes are written on the
back of these and passed to customers
and with the money and supplies going
missing people have started looking for
Jimmy and Natalie Natalie could blame
Leonard for her boyfriend's death but
instead she sees something in common
with the character they're about
survivors that lost the ones they loved
and they're now trying to get even with
the person who took everything away from
them in the black and white flashbacks
that follow we learned that Leonard
worked in insurance and the skills he
got here have helped his life massively
he learned to read body language namely
when someone was lying but here we see
that isn't really the case in fact every
character that Lenny interacts with is
lying to him and he's pretty much
surrounded by sharks and sinking very
quickly now from here we jump to a scene
with Teddy clearly aware that Natalie is
trying to get him he even suggests that
Lenny could be after the wrong guy very
careful why the other day you mentioned
that maybe somebody was trying to set
you up
to kill the wrong game well I go on
facts not recommendations but thank you
speaking of lies at the discount in we
we find that birds actually renting him
out two rooms he's paying twice as much
because he's taking advantage of him and
it shows how everyone around Lenny is
using him in some way now from here we
catch Lenny's investigation into Sammy
Jenkins he starts to believe he's not
telling the truth because Sammy gives
him almost a look of recognition
whenever he shows up at the house
however we learn that this is something
Sammy carried out because he didn't want
to make people feel uncomfortable he
wanted to pretend that he remembered
them so that they wouldn't feel bad
making it even more tragic Sami was
given several tests as it was thought he
would instinctively avoid electrocuting
himself however this didn't happen
unless his claim was denied his wife was
stuck with the medical bills and it
ruined both of them or her and Lenny I
don't know anyway Sammy is tested by a
doctor who Nolan also casts in The Dark
Knight Rises in a doctor role Thomas
Lennon plays both these parts and he
said that he at least likes to think
that they're the same person now after
Don is revealed and Leonard's cupboard
Teddy shows up and the pair drive out we
get a focus on Teddy's license plate
which ends in 7-1u but this letter
changes to 7 IU perhaps adding how much
of an unreliable narrator that Lenny is
and how it's all potentially in his head
mental Asylum
again also we are selling Theory time
clothing right now on our merch store
Zero edition so if you want to support
the channel and get something back then
make sure you check that out in the
comments section below now this idea of
him having unreliable memories is also
shown in the photo that Natalie ends up
giving to him in one we can see Jimmy
has a mustache whereas in the other one
he doesn't Natalie too is posed
differently and this again adds to the
idea of him misremembering things or
seeing them different to how they
actually are you also have some fun with
the props too as Teddy's license play
expires on the 29th of February this
isn't a real day due to it not being a
leap year and there's they're kind of
playing around and messing with the
audience a bit anyway we see a scene at
night in which Lenny drives out to burn
his wife's belongings this includes a
buck that she had which she read so many
times that the cover's fallen off and
the pages have started to curl Lenny
even asks her why she keeps reading it
again and she says how can you read that
again
it's good
yeah you read it like a thousand times
I enjoy it now this is very much a
reflection of Lenny's life with him
being stuck in the same story going
through it over and over and over again
he also Burns a clock which no price for
guessing what the symbolism with that is
now after another black and white scene
we watch Lenny waking up with the
belongings that he's about to go and
burn here we can see them set up around
the room and this is exactly like how he
had them in his old house who does this
because it gives him the feeling for a
few moments that his wife's still alive
now it turns out that he's hired an
escort and this is so he can relive the
time when he believed he was happy now
Nolan did go back and forth though or
whether to keep this scene in the movie
or not but he settled on its staying
because it shows Lenny's willing to
manipulate himself which plays into the
ending in a flashback we see Leonard
being visited by Sammy's wife who asks
him flat out whether he's faking his
condition Leonard denies it and it leads
to her apparent death it's very much
Karma with the same thing possibly
happening to Leonard and his wife but I
think the chances of two people being
affected by this condition are extremely
rare obviously let me know below if you
think Sammy was a real person or not or
or if it's just a projection so Leonard
can save himself from the guilt now
Leonard then goes to his car and he
finds Teddy inside because he left it
unlocked Teddy has been waiting there
but he can't drive off with it because
he doesn't have the keys and doesn't
want to move the money himself at the
end of the film Lenny throws his car
keys away and I don't think that he ever
finds them which could be another reason
why he's constantly trying to get the
car Lenny stayed at Natalie's but
Teddy's the one who suggests the motel
because it takes him away from her we
see all the stuff when Natalie and her
true side and how she actually speaks to
Leonard she tells him that she's going
to use him and that she's gonna enjoy it
and loads on him like it's the YouTube
comment section and you've got one thing
wrong in your 4 000 word video script
it's so Sinister how Natalie sits in the
car staring at him and she waits for him
to forget and we of course seen the
scene before how she plays this whole
thing out now he then see her bringing
him over to her house in the next scene
and she moves the newspaper off some
food this is a real estate guide and
obviously Natalie lives a very dangerous
life so it's possible that she and her
boyfriend would constantly be looking at
other places there's also a rotten apple
as well and calling someone a rotten
apple of course means they're a bad
person Natalie it's probably the
wickedest character that we meet and I
love the way that Nolan uses this to
symbolize it we get a split second shot
where he Flex his syringe and this is
also something that we saw Sami doing
with his wife again this ties the
characters together and since they're
both doing a similar way it could be
hitting at them being one and the same
Kurt back to the motel and we see Lenny
refusing to take calls due to a tattoo
warning him against it at this point an
envelopes passed under the door and it
shows a photo of him pointing to his
heart now this is very very important
and it shows the extent that Teddy's
manipulated him we discover that Lenny
was putting to his heart because he was
gonna get a tattoo there to show that he
got his wife's killer this means that
every time he looked at it he'd know he
managed to catch them and get his
revenge Leonard's Polaroids are very
much his memories and they're what he
uses to keep things in order now Teddy
snapped this Photograph because it would
be used as a way for Lenny to remember
to go and get the tattoo there so he
could finally be free from his quest for
Revenge However the fact that Teddy
passed this under the door shows that he
took this from him Teddy stole the
memory of this because he didn't want
Leonard to move on and in fact he wanted
to keep using him he gives him the photo
back here as a way to manipulate him and
will constantly use it to get Leonard to
open up then he goes to the bar because
Acosta tells him about Natalie however
as we learn he's actually wearing her
boyfriend's clothes and this coaster was
a message for him so here she gets
everyone is spitting Lenny's strength to
test if he actually has memory issues or
not like Sammy he doesn't remember it
but she does take it off him in the
former scene after hearing about his
wife's murder we then curted the tattoo
shop where Teddy tries to warn Lenny by
telling him about himself because the
cops looking for you whoa what cop
he's a bad cop
he's the one that checked into the
discount at he's been calling you for
days now telling you [ __ ] slipping
envelopes under your door [ __ ] like that
knows you're no good on the phone so
he's been calling you up sometimes you
don't answer the phone so he slips [ __ ]
under your door to scare you into
answering the phone again giving you a
line of crap about John G being some
local drug dealer in his pocket he finds
a coaster and also sees the burn
photograph which we know was him
pointing at his heart we see the scene
with Jimmy playing out and discover that
he has 200 Grand stuffed in the back of
his car he kills him and steals his
clothes which is when Teddy arrives at
this point Teddy reveals the truth after
Leonard realizes that Jimmy wasn't the
killer this is a gut-wrenching scene in
which he says Sammy never had a wife and
that it's Lenny's wife who was actually
diabetic Lenny believes he wasn't and
it's a complete head for the audience
and the director's commentary goes in
depth on this with nulling going through
what this scene means he stayed at this
point Lenny very much becomes the
audience and just like him we aren't
prepared for the truth we also don't
fully Act accept the answers even after
Teddy shows him the photograph Lenny
still doesn't really believe it and he
burns all of this evidence Nolan state
that they deliberately chose Polaroids
because they couldn't be ripped up like
a Cod photograph could thus they have to
be burned and Lenny is symbolically
burning through the thing that's given
him a purpose so he can continue to have
a purpose he writes down Teddy's license
plate and draws the eyes a straight line
which again could be interpreted as an
IRA one he then drives off and he looks
at his hand to focus on the Sami janka's
tattoo he does this because it
reinforces the idea that he has to stick
to the path and the story that he's on
now to add even more of a head to it
Nolan actually recorded four different
endings for the commentary with each one
lasting roughly 20 minutes for the final
part of the film these are selected
randomly every time you put the disc in
and depending on what one you get it
could drastically change major parts of
the film the first one has him saying
Teddy is lying whilst the second one
says that he's telling the truth the
third basically says this is all a
monotonous thing for Teddy and it also
adds that his license plate is
sg-137iu which is the postcode for
Nolan's old school the last one has the
final 20 minutes playing in Reverse so
you currently understand it so yeah who
knows if we'll ever know the truth and
Nolan is deliberately keeping this
ambiguous for us to take our own
interpretations I think that's the
perfect point to turn things over to you
and also ask you to let me know what you
think's going on with the movie Memento
is a classic and to me it always has
been this is one of Nolan's strongest
films and going back to it just reminded
me of how good this movie is the reveals
are crushing and the characters are so
complex and it's very very tragic the
movie is such a great study of The Human
Condition and it's packed with a lot of
things in it that I hope this video
helps you to appreciate huge thank you
for checking this out and please hit the
Thumbs Up Button And subscribe on your
way out if you want something else to
watch we have a big breakdown of
interstellar which will be linked on
screen right now now the way I've been
Paul I hope to see on the next one you
take care yourself and all the best for
the New Year peace